[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten haben die ihnen allen schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den sport als schirm unter von mir
haben unter anderem diese themen für sie
signale aus moskau nach dem nato-gipfel
kündigt präsident putin gegenmaßnahmen
an zieht aber zugleich seine soldaten
von der ukrainischen schlangen insel ab
corona im sommer die inzidenz hat sich
in diesem juni verdreifacht seit heute
sind bürger tests für fast alle wieder
kostenpflichtig
und das sterben in den meeren versalzung
und fischerei bedrohen die artenvielfalt
auch die seepferdchen an der algarve
die nato präsentiert sich zum abschluss
ihres gipfels geeint und entschlossen
wie lange nicht wir werden jeden
zentimeter nato gebiet verteidigen warnt
der amerikanische präsident richtung
moskau die ukraine soll noch mehr auch
schwere waffen bekommen die aufnahme von
schweden und finnland schon kommende
woche offiziell besiegelt werden aus
madrid berichtet el mati wissen zu große
nähe ist manchen noch etwas unangenehm
aber dass man zusammenhalten muss weil
es die lage erfordert das ist die eine
lehre von matt die andere dass es viel
geld kostet die freiheit zu verteidigen
hunderte milliarden dollar investieren
sie in ihre militärhaushalte und den
massiven truppenaufbau an der ostflanke
den vorwurf putins die nato zeige
imperialistische tendenzen weisen sie
hier entschlossen zurück das ist
ehrlicher weise ziemlich lächerlich denn
tatsächlich ist die nato eine defensive
allianz sie keine anderen länder an
und hat auch das nicht vor sie ist für
niemanden in seine eigenen nachbarschaft
eine
bedrohung in die nato wird nicht nur
stärker sondern auch einiger und die
demokratien der welt stehen gegen die
aggression auf und verteidigen die
regelbasierte ordnung genau das ist es
was wir heute sehen
ja es dreht sich was im bündnis aber im
schock des ukraine krieges übertüncht es
nur die risse beseitigen kann es sie
nicht dennoch gibt es im zdf-interview
lob für die bundesregierung als vorbild
bei der neuausrichtung der nato
deutschland führt durch sein beispiel
weil er seine spezifische brigade für
die verteidigung litauens vorsehen wird
zusätzlich zu der von deutschland
geführten kampf gruppe die bereits in
litauen ist
die gipfel von madrid und elmau sollen
meilensteine seien in dem vorhaben die
werte und rechte basierte ordnung zu
verteidigen gegen den autoritär ismus
aller russland und china die beschlüsse
sind weitreichend aber nur dann
glaubwürdig wenn den worten wirklich
taten folgen der zusammenhalt soll
halten nicht nur bis zum nächsten
nato-gipfel der soll auch das ein signal
in vilnius stattfinden der hauptstadt
litauens
das ganze interview mit
nato-generalsekretär ians deutenberg
sehen sie bei maybrit illner heute um
viertel nach zieht der russische
präsident putin hat gegenmaßnahmen
angekündigt wenn nato-truppen in
finnland und schweden stationiert werden
und wie sind die reaktionen in russland
selbst christian senn mit stimmen und
stimmungen aus moskau
in moskau wurden schon witze gemacht
über den schlechten sommer in diesem
jahr vielleicht sei das miese wetter ja
teil der westlichen sanktionen jetzt
aber genießen die menschen die schönen
tage und was in der ukraine passiert
scheint weit weg geteilte meinungen über
die nord erweiterung der nato
das ist eine bedrohung für russland wenn
die nato so nahe kommt ist das schlecht
man muss mehr abstand von ihr halten
jetzt ist die nato noch näher an
russland herangegangen aufgrund putins
politik öffentliche kritik an der von
russland so genannten speziellen militär
operation ist verboten und gefährlich
strafen drohen in sachen nato
erweiterung sagt putin weder mit
finnland noch mit schweden habe man
territoriale probleme aber jetzt werde
es spannungen geben das sei klar bei
seinem besuch gestern in turkmenistan
betonte putin er habe nichts gegen einen
nato-beitritt schwedens und finnlands
aber
wenn jetzt nato-truppen und
infrastruktur aufgebaut werden werden
wir gezwungen sein in gleicher weise zu
reagieren und die gleichen bedrohungen
zu schaffen für die gebiete von denen
bedrohungen gegen uns ausgehen
bewegung scheint es in einer anderen
wichtigen frage zu geben moskau kündigte
an sich in der ukraine von der
umkämpften und strategisch wichtigen
schlangen insel im schwarzen meer
zurückzuziehen hier feiert den abzug als
militärischen erfolg moskau hingegen
spricht von einer geste des guten
willens um den weg freizumachen für die
so wichtigen getreideexporte aus der
ukraine
wir verhindern nicht dem export von
klinischen geht reisen die ukrainischen
militärbehörden haben die zufahrten zu
ihren häfen vermählt und niemand hindert
sie daran ihre mühen zu räumen und stufe
mit getreide von dort raus zu lassen wir
garantieren sicherheit
die ukraine will sich darauf nicht
verlassen putin sucht währenddessen nach
neuen allianzen in der welt heute war
der indonesische präsident widodo im
kreml gastgeber des g20-gipfels im
november noch habe putin nicht
entschieden heißt es ob er persönlich
nach bali reisen oder nur online teil
im streit um den transitverkehr nach
kaliningrad zeichnet sich möglicherweise
eine lösung ab polens ministerpräsident
sagte in die eu und russland seien
bereit zu verhandeln es geht um den
landverkehr zwischen dem russischen
kernland in die russische exklave
litauen hatte russische lieferungen
teilweise blockiert mit hinweis auf die
eu sanktionen
nach deutschland der appell der
regierung energie vor allem gas zu
sparen scheint zu fruchten
hierzulande ging der gasverbrauch bis
ende mai um rund 14 prozent zurück
trotzdem bleibt die versorgungslage
kritisch
wirtschaftsminister habe es schlicht
schließt nicht aus dass russland mitte
juli den gashahn ganz zudrehen könnte
als erster großer deutscher versorger
schlägt jetzt juniper alarm und fordert
staatshilfe ariane
hier fließt 60 prozent weniger gas aus
russland als vertraglich zugesichert ein
problem für deutsche gasversorger wie
juniper als größter der branche schlägt
der börsennotierte konzern alarm
juniper nutzt ersatzbeschaffungen um die
versorgungssicherheit seine kunden zu
gewährleisten
die beschaffung von ersatz mengen
erfolgt jedoch aktuell zu deutlich
höheren preisen
preise die der gasgroßhändler aufgrund
langfristiger verträge bislang nicht an
seine kunden wie zb stadtwerke
weitergeben kann juniper ruf nach
staatlicher hilfe das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium bestätigt
dass bereits gespräche über
stabilisierungsmaßnahmen stattfinden ein
richtiger und wichtiger schritt so
verbraucherschützer
juniper beliefert mehrere hundert
stadtwerke hat verträge über
gaslieferungen und wenn jetzt das
unternehmen in schieflage gerät diese
verträge nicht einhalten kann dann ist
es natürlich unmittelbar dann kommt es
sehr schnell bei den kunden an deswegen
ist es wichtig dass die bundesregierung
jetzt hier ein hilfspaket schnitt in
anderen europäischen ländern ist die
weitergabe gestiegener preise an die
verbraucher nicht so reglementiert wie
hier das ist der grund warum die
inflation also die weitergabe der
bisherigen erdgas preissteigerungen in
deutschland langsamer vonstatten geht
als etwa in anderen europäischen ländern
das heißt aber auch gleichzeitig dass
noch nicht alle preissteigerungen auf
dem weltmarkt in deutschland
weitergegeben worden
sind
gasversorger brauchen mehr geld entweder
vom staat oder vom kunden
bei der zahl der arbeitslosen werden
erstmals auch ukrainische die
flüchtlinge flüchtete über die jobcenter
erfasst trotzdem der deutsche
arbeitsmarkt ist stabil und wegen des
hohen arbeitskräftebedarf vieler
branchen findet keine verdrängung stadt
sagt der chef der bundesagentur für
arbeit scheele im juni waren zwei
millionen
363.000 menschen ohne job 103.000 mehr
als im mai die quote erhöhte sich um 0,3
punkte auf 5,2 prozent im vergleich zum
juni 21 sind heute
251.000 menschen weniger arbeitslos
jetzt zu corona wir sind mittendrin in
der sommer- welle zwar fehlen
verlässliche zahlen weil nur noch wenige
infizierte einen pcr-test machen aber
die inzidenz stieg zuletzt wieder stark
an allein in diesem monat hat er sich
mehr als verdreifacht
umstritten ist deshalb dass ab heute
corona tests wieder bezahlt werden
müssen kostenlos sind sie nur noch für
bestimmte gruppen etwa für kinder bis
fünf jahre für besucher von
krankenhäusern oder pflegeheimen für
pflegende angehörige oder nahe
angehörige von infizierten jan fischer
und svend glas berichten
bis zum frühen morgen waren sie hier in
wendlingen beschäftigt haben sich die
details der neuen test regeln über das
internet zusammen gesucht und müssen
jetzt erstmal die besucher aufklären was
genau für wen ab sofort gilt das sind
sehr viele die einfach freude an die
station kommen und erstmal für uns kein
verständnis haben wo wir es halt weiter
gehen müssen sagen okay wir müssen ab
heute die neue forderungen umsetzen
anlasslose kostenlose bürger test für
alle sind damit geschichte sie haben den
bund zuletzt rund eine milliarde euro
pro monat gekostet die tests sollen nun
gezielt zum schutz wilder gruppen
eingesetzt werden und so bleiben die
tests eben nur noch in manchen fällen
kostenlos andere müssen drei euro zu
zahlen etwa besucher von veranstaltungen
innenräume personen mit kontakt zur
risikopersonen und person mit roter
krawatte für alle anderen kosten tests
mit unter 15 euro
für die drei euro auszahlen also ich
finde es jetzt nicht so schlimm es ist
wahrscheinlich die gefahr dass dass ich
jetzt weniger leute dazu kommt um
weiterhin anspruch auf einen bürger test
zu haben muss der grund dafür glaubhaft
belegt werden man ist immer auf die
ehrlichkeit der bürger angewiesen aber
derjenige der den test würde
unterschreibt das ja und werden
beispielsweise die großmutter in der
pflegeeinrichtung ist dann braucht man
von der pflegeeinrichtung ein formblatt
was unterschieden ist die kontrolle
dieser nachweise sie könnte kompliziert
werden doch die anpassung sei ein
richtiger schritt sagt der experte
wissenschaftlich ist es nun mal so dass
diese anlasslosen test tatsächlich wenig
zur erklärung und zur datenlage beim
infektionsgeschehen beigetragen haben ob
die neue test strategie des bundes
wirklich aufgeht spätestens im herbst
wird sich das zeigen
einen monat gibt es jetzt das neue euro
ticket und es hat die erwartungen der
verkehrsunternehmen übertroffen 21
millionen mal verkauft dazu die zehn
millionen inhaber von zeitkarten so kam
es oft zu vollen warmen den weg zur
arbeit machte es für viele günstiger
ebenso ausflüge es gab weniger staus
verkehrsbetriebe und städtetag fordern
eine anschlusslösung doch finanzminister
lindner sieht für weitere entlastungen
keinen spielraum für
die betroffenen ist es enorm wichtig und
längst überfällig künftig soll jeder
mensch sein geschlecht und seinen
vornamen selbst festlegen und
unkompliziert ändern lassen können so
steht's im entwurf der bundesregierung
für das neue selbstbestimmung gesetz es
ersetzt das mehr als 40 jahre alte
transsexuellengesetz heike slansky
silicea roulette ist nach einem langen
leidensweg endlich mit sich im reinen
schon sehr früh fühlte sie sich nicht
wohl in ihrem geschlecht sie kam als
junge zur welt konnte aber mit den
erwartungen die daran geknüpft sind
nicht leben ich wusste sich kein junge
bin seit ich fünf bin eigentlich quasi
jede erinnerung die ich habe ist da
ziemlich eindeutig mit 17 zog sie vom
land nach berlin fand gleichgesinnte
entschied sich für eine
geschlechtsumwandlung laut
transsexuellengesetz singt nur für die
juristische namens und geschlechts
änderung zwei gutachten nötig hohe
kosten ein termin vorm amtsgericht die
ampel will das nun ändern und stellte
eckpunkte für ein neues sogenanntes
selbstbestimmung gesetz vor trans
geschlechtliche menschen haben nicht das
geschlecht das eben bei der geburt
zugewiesen wurde viele außenstehende
verhöhnen das so dass diese menschen zu
einer besonders wohlhabenden gruppe in
unserer gesellschaft gehören das ist
keine krankheit sondern es ist auch wenn
es nicht der statistische normalfall ist
trotzdem ein stück normalität und
deshalb wollen wir mit diesen menschen
respektvoll umgehen künftig soll man
sein geschlecht und vornamen selbst
festlegen können ab 14 jahren mit
einwilligung der eltern oder eines
familiengerichts kritik kommt von der
union nach unserer auffassung sollte es
in jedem fall auch bei erwachsenen eine
ergebnisoffene beratung geben es sollte
auch erst nach mehreren jahren und nicht
jährlich möglich sein der minderjährige
schutz kommt uns viel zu kurz und gerade
auch im bereich des sportes und in
vielen anderen bereichen gibt es noch
viele ungeklärte fragen sie ließ ihr
freut sich dass die hohen hürden bald
wegfallen und das recht auf
selbstbestimmung und gesellschaftliche
teilhabe gestärkt wird
die weltmeere zeigen sich oft längst
nicht mehr so idyllisch wie hier bei
einer uno konferenz in lissabon geht es
gerade um probleme wie überfischung
riesige müllberge und den klimawandel
dessen folgen bekommen zum beispiel auch
seepferdchen zu spüren an der
portugiesischen algarve schrumpft ihr
bestand weil die lagune rundum faro zu
salzig wird was helfen soll zeigt thomas
walde
die ria formosa im südosten portugals
ist eines der größten lagunen gebiete
europas hier zeigen sich die probleme
der kleinsten lebewesen
seit monaten oder besser seit jahren
habe ich keine sieg wird mir hier
gesehen nichts mehr und früher gab es
die überall der meeresspiegel steigt
salz kommt in die süßwasser lagune die
seepferdchen gehen heute gibt es sie
fast nur in der station der universität
algarve
hauptgrund für den rückgang der
seepferdchen bevölkerung ist der mensch
der die qualität der lebensräume für sie
stark zerstört hat
die universität agave forscht nicht nur
über umweltfolgen sie züchtet auch
seepferdchen von den kleinsten zwei
wochen alt bis zu zwei jahren im wasser
aus der lagune dort kommen sie auch
wieder hin inbesondere schutzzonen
wir haben festgestellt dass die zahl der
17 in den neuen schutzzonen wesentlich
größer ist als außerhalb
in die schutzzonen darf kein boot und
fischen ist verboten dennoch finden
parkwächter solche tintenfisch käfige
die illegale fischerei schade den sieg
werten denn sie können in den käfigen
hängen bleiben und dort sterben dieses
hier haben wir in so einem käfig
gefunden
bis zum jahr 2030 will portugal nicht
nur die ria formosa sondern fast ein
drittel seines meeres gebietes unter
naturschutz stellen
und jetzt zum sport norbert auch heute
wieder fast eine deutsche goldmedaille
bei der schwimm-em ja fast schon etwas
unheimlich gestern verpasste leonie beck
im freiwasser über 10 kilometer nur
haarscharf ihr zweites gold in budapest
und heute war es lena beuth über die 25
kilometer nach fast fünfeinhalb stunden
schwimmen fehlten der ganze zwei zehntel
sekunden zum sieg
gestern ist es ein trio heute an
quartett im schlussspurt und das über
die längste distanz im freiwasser die es
gibt nach leonie beck silber über 10
kilometer ist es nunmehr bei die zum
abschluss im freiwasser einen
herausragenden erfolg feiert beim
mobilisiert darüber 24,9 kilometer noch
einmal ihre letzten kräfte bei 28 grad
wassertemperatur und schlägt einen
wimpernschlag vor der niederländerin van
rauendahl an die zehn kilometer
weltmeisterin witt dritte boy gewinnt
silber die neunte wm medaille für das
deutsche team so erfolgreich wie 2011
platz eins geht an brasilien an eine
erschöpft glückliche ana marcela cunha
die schwestern elena und cristina
wachsen dagegen haben in budapest eine
wm medaille verpasst im finale des
synchronspringen vom turm mussten sich
die beiden mit dem fünften platz
begnügen
gold ging wie schon in den sieben
anderen vielleicht zuvor an die
wassersprung nach china das duo aus den
usa wurde zweiter
er soll das herzstück des deutschen
fußballs sein der neue dfb campus in
frankfurt präsident bernd neuendorf und
direktor oliver bierhoff weiten heute
offiziell den neuen verbandssitz 150
millionen euro hat der gebäudekomplex
gekostet 500 dfb mitarbeiter sind dort
tätig und auf den vier fußballplätzen da
können sich die deutschen nationalteams
regelmäßig auf ihre heimspiele
vorbereiten
beim chio in aachen hat frederik
wanderes auf duke of britain im dressur
grand prix das beste deutsche ergebnis
erzielt im team
der 35 jährige wurde nach einer
fehlerfreien runde zweiter rekord
olympiasiegerin isabell werth mit
quantas nur fünfter souveräne
tagessiegerin die dänen kathrin die fuhr
mit warmer sunny cars
dänemark führt jetzt in der
nationenwertung knapp vor deutschland
und die entscheidung dann am samstag
danke schön euer zum schluss noch einen
riesenapplaus für die kollegen und
kolleginnen von logo die zdf
kindernachrichten bekommen den hanns
joachim friedrichs sonderpreis
komplizierte welt lage klar erklärt
nicht selten besser und nun auf geräte
als es bei den großen gelungen ist
journalistische aufklärung im besten
sinne so begründet es die jury zu sehen
ist logo übrigens im kinderkanal kika
der deutsche wetterdienst warnt aktuell
vor schweren gewittern und heftigen
starkregen in nordrhein westfalen
rheinland pfalz baden württemberg und
bayern mehr dazu gleich mit christa oben
das heute journal mit christian sievers
um viertel vor zehn danke für ihr
interesse einen schönen abend noch und
bis morgen wenn sie mögen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend eine kaltfront hat jetzt den
äußersten westen des landes erreicht und
schiebt sich heute nacht und morgen
einmal über das land hinter der front
wird es deutlich kühler und davor gibt's
einige kräftige gewitter heute nacht ist
vor allem im südwesten da noch die große
gefahr vor starkregen hagel und
sturmböen sonst kommt die front bis zu
einer linie nordsee bayerischer wald
voran davor da bleibt es noch klar
trotzdem wird die nacht sehr mild morgen
früh mit 16 bis 19 grad dahinter ist es
aber schon kühler morgen früh hier 11
bis 15 grad morgen spielen wir dann
praktisch überall einen temperatursturz
muss heute 30 grad gab sind es morgen
nur noch 20 grad an den alpen sogar nur
17 grad ganz im osten da haben wir
nochmal 28 grad dahin verschiebt sich
dann morgen im tagesverlauf auch die
gewittertätigkeit mit lokalen unwetter
von westen her gibt es dann eine
wetterberuhigung dazwischen setzt aber
auch mal länger regen ein vor allem aus
den alpen heraus bis nach franken bis zu
25 litern pro quadratmetern auch morgen
noch mal und in den trockenen regionen
im osten kommen auch um die 15 liter pro
quadratmetern außerhalb der gewitter
noch mal zusammen am wochenende ist dann
aber schon wieder trocken und das wird
auch wieder heiß mit bis 30 grad tschüss